And at last, we have the final diagram summarizing everything that we have done.
This example is just meant to illustrate what real problem solving is like.
In real model building, we make choices that we think will lead to new insights,
which then reveal new paths of analysis,
which build upon previous knowledge to gradually arrive at the model.
Very soon, we'll work together through a complete example from the ground up to
see the iterative cycles of question, model and validate built upon each other.
You'll see how to turn a vague question into a rigorous problem of
statistical inference through successive refinement.
You'll learn to identify possible next iterations and
how to use them to generate possible paths of analysis.
By the end of this lesson, you will feel confident in your ability to
tackle new difficult problems and start making progress with them.
The choices we make during each phase can be diagrammed in
a tree like the one here.
It's a useful tool for considering our possible paths forward during analysis,
as well as revealing options for revisiting steps when you
must inevitably adjust decisions made during earlier phases.
In the rest of this lesson, we will apply each of these steps to an actual data
set and you will get a chance to follow along and practice these steps with us.